under the notification that will be
go give me just one moment
okay
are you jeffrey i'm fine i had to step
out to uh mute the dog
your dog has a mute setting okay
wow does
please go ahead chairwoman webber okay
and i am now going to open
this meeting of the house health human
services
and elderly affairs committee it is
thursday september 3rd
at 2 p.m uh and as
chair of the house health human services
and elderly affairs committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
person went to executive order 2020
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am hereby confirming that we are
a providing public access to the meeting
by telephone with additional access
possibilities by video or other
electronic means
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access
to contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting
by clicking on the following website
address
https colon backslash
uh forward slash forward slash zoom dot
u s slash j
slash nine three six three
nine six nine eight five
seven or dialing one of the following
phone numbers
one three one two six two six
six seven nine nine or one
nine two nine two zero five
six zero nine nine uh
b providing public notice of the
necessary information for accessing the
meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
c providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the public body during the
meeting if there are problems with
access
if anybody has a problem please call
271 3600
or email c hcs
at l e g dot
state dot n h
dot u s d
adjourning the meeting if the public is
unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
assisting
that are on the meeting assisting us
christina dyer
is the meeting host additional staff
providing support are jennifer four
and bradley greenland this is a work
session
on bills referred to the house health
human services and elderly affairs
committee for interim study
an executive session will follow copies
of the interim study bills have been
posted on the main page of the general
court website under the heading remote
meetings
please note that all votes are taken
during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
we are going to start the meeting with a
roll call attendance
i am going to note that if there is a
member of the committee
who is attending via telephone
they can use star 6 to unmute themselves
and star 9 to raise their hand
so star 6 will unmute you so that you
can reply to the attendance when it's
called
so we're going to start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there's anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law and
madam clerk when you are ready you may
start to take the attendance
thank you madam chair champion
here and i am alone oops
sorry just pencil broke um
mckay
[Music]
so i can
um shall i go on yes i think so
okay snow here and my wife is in the
vicinity but not the room
freitas i'm here alone
tysers i am here alone at the moment i
do
expect someone will join me during this
meeting
canarik yes i am here alone in my study
my wife is in the house but not in
attendance here
salloway bellowing is here at his home
office
in lee new hampshire alone but for the
dog
cannon hi i'm here
there's no one else in the room narrow
up him
yes i'm here and there's someone else to
[Music]
osborne
i'm not hearing a response shapiro
could you call the name a second time
before you before you go on
certainly will osborne
shapiro hello i'm here in my house
in a room by myself woods
uh yes i'm uh home alone
mcmahon present and i am home and
isolated nelson
here with the dog thanks
guthrie i'm in my kitchen i'm alone and
my wife is in the building
father gill
marsh good afternoon i am at home alone
in my office
in brookfield pearson
i am here in my office
at our medical center and alone with the
door closed
acton
de klerk
de clerk
stapleton stapleton is in his office in
claremont new hampshire
alone at the moment but my wife may pass
through
some time and weber
i am here in my residence in walpole and
i am alone except for a dog
so with that um
i think we will proceed um
i'm going to take up the bills in the
order uh in numerical order just so that
it's easier to follow along i used to
skip around and i'm i'm going to
remind people that normally
when we have interim study bills at this
point
we will have had a very robust
subcommittee procedure
and the robust subcommittee chairman
will come in and make a recommendation
based on
on what happened at subcommittee but we
are having the work session right now
and each work session will immediately
be followed by
an executive session on that bill so
the first bill we are taking up is house
bill
1265 relative to the requirement of
qualifying medical conditions for
prescriptions for therapeutic cannabis
and i'm also going to remind the members
just before we start
that what we will come out with at the
end of this is simply a recommendation
for
further legislation or a
recommendation that the bill is not
should not be the subject of further
legislation so with that
um we have house bill 1265 before us
and if anybody has a comment they want
to make
they can either wave at me as
representative knark is doing or raise
their hand
via the little raise their hand function
but i have seen representative knark
so i'm going to recognize him thank you
madam chair
um basically just to remember i'm
currently serving as the chair of the
therapeutic cannabis medical oversight
board and we're tasked with overseeing
the medical
issues including qualifying conditions
and that medical oversight board is
composed of the medical director of
dhhs a qualifying patient a
representative in atc and 10 different
medical providers from various fields
we discussed this bill in our january
2020 meeting
and we voted that this bill should be
voted in expedient to legislate
eight to zero with two abstentions and
there are basically two reasons number
one is
that it concludes the words for which
cannabis is prescribed which we do not
prescribe
cannabis as providers we simply certify
that the person can obtain
cannabis through an alternative
treatment center the second
is the wording of stating a qualified
medical
qualified medical condition means a
medical condition diagnosed by a
provider for which cannabis
is prescribed may include the presence
of
really opens the door wide open to
allowing anything because it doesn't say
it's restricted to that but it only may
include that
so we have actually been against the
idea of
having no qualifying conditions for a
couple of basic reasons
we feel that uh the current
uh provider community really doesn't
have enough
skill set in cannabis to know what is
appropriate
for use of cannabis and what isn't
we we aren't taught this in medically
certainly we're taught this in medical
school when
i was there and i'm not sure how much of
it's even taught now
granted providers can get the
information but
uh we spend hours and hours when we
deliberate as our own board with a
number of people that are specialists in
this
so we feel that the overall provider
knowledge base is not sufficient to open
the door wide open
we our work um plan for all of 2020 has
been to develop
educational provider materials we've
been working diligently on that and by
the end of the year we expect to have
our web page launched
with a number of different uh
educational materials available for
providers we do not
demand certification a certification
course for
qualifying providers in this state some
states do we don't
so basically the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight board thinks this
should not go forward
and if it's appropriate to make a motion
at this time i would
move that this uh bill well let's hold
on to the motion
until we go into okay thank you an
actual executive session
but yes uh so let me ask if there's
anybody else who wants
to make a comment at this point
go ahead thank you madam chair it's just
a point of order for my clerking duties
the
form that i have to fill out for the
subcommittee work session
does include a motion to either
recommend or not recommend
right um oh
so you're saying that you think we could
just go right ahead and do the executive
session concurrently
no if i'm to fill out my paperwork
properly which
i'm not wedded to but if i am to then i
would need to record
a recommendation of this at the
subcommittee work session
and then a motion at the executive i
think
so yes representative kirk i gather
we're going to take
two votes on this because we are acting
as a subcommittee of the whole
so i believe that your recommendation
was not recommended for further
um action is that correct yes that is
correct i would move that we should
that hb1265 should be not recommended
for further legislative action
okay i will second the motion
i'm sorry who was that representative
marsh would like to second the motion
uh representative marsh we thank you for
your second
now is there any further discussion at
the subcommittee level
representative snow has his hand up
representative snow
go right ahead you're going to have to
un unmute yourself representative snow
okay i'm unmuted there you go my only
reason for raising my hand is i want to
raise questions about the word
prescription and that's now been taken
prescribed and that's now taken care of
okay thank you representative snow
are there further comments
ms dyer do you see anybody else wishing
i do not comment on behalf of the
committee
there being no further comments with
respect to the subcommittee work
when she is ready the
motion here is not recommended for
further
action and when she is ready
uh the clerk can call the role on that
motion on house bill 1265.
thank you madam chair champion
yes uh mckay is not present snow
yes freitas yes
tice hurst yes canaric
yes um osborne
shapiro yes woods
yes uh mcmahon is
not present i'm sorry man
yes i apologize
nelson yes guthrie
joe on mu guthrie
representative guthrie you need to
unmute
do we still have representatives we have
representative guthrie he needs to
unmute his computer
how is that that's much better
i didn't do that on purpose i hope
nobody did it that's okay
uh what's your vote representative
guthrie it is yes
thank you sir marsh yes
pearson yes and stapleton
yes and weber yes
believe that would be 17-0 okay
and representative clerk you will make
the motion when we go to executive
session
i'm now going to close the work session
on
house bill 1265 and open the executive
session on house bill 1265
and i'm going to entertain a motion and
representative knurk is
is recognized for the motion yes i move
that hb 1265 be
not recommended for for further
legislation
and representative marsh are you still
second yes
i thank you sir uh is there any further
discussion
seeing none when she is ready the clerk
may call the role
um for the final recommendation on house
bill 1265 the motion is
not recommended for further legislation
i had a question
oh yes go right ahead representative
shapiro um
i would just like to ask representative
kanerk
based on his comments about the cannabis
oversight board
if there's a thought that in the future
that doctors will be able to prescribe
for any condition they feel is relevant
and what and what time frame that might
include
go ahead representative you may respond
well we would actually never prescribe
remember this is a prohibited substance
um it's a schedule one substance so we
would not actually truly prescribe
but it means certify right i don't know
the answer to that
i think we would need some follow-up
work to find out what level of
competence people have developed
um our concern has always been people
becoming
even now it falls into two different
camps people who never prescribe
and people who prescribe relatively
easily but we don't want to make
uh providers and decisives who will just
prescribe for anything to get the person
out of their office
or sorry certified all right sorry
not prescribed yeah right certify for
anything
uh just to get the person out of their
office like they sometimes do for
prescribing
you know sleeping pills um so it is a
bit of a concern though it's a little
bit more work
for certification and it is a one-year
certification has to be renewed
so there is some actual provider work
for doing this and might not be
as abused as prescription writing is for
many
common medications but i'm not sure on
that we you know we made a decision when
we put in this program
that we would not just open the door
that would just be a limiting number of
uh conditions but it is a major uh
job of our board is to review these and
we have to go back and weed out a number
of
conditions which maybe should be removed
thank you representative nurse are there
any further comments representative
woods
uh yes just a sidebar on that there was
a group of us
uh some at dartmouth and one from
vermont
uh about this issue um apparently
and i apologize for not having you know
um verse and
a chapter and verse on this but
apparently in the rsa
is that physicians can offer guidelines
uh not prescription but guidelines and
in that is
they have to be followed uh that was in
the uh again with the thought
that um those that are providing
uh medications for seizures do not want
any thc
but only cbd's and so
that was a guideline that has to be
followed
so there is a modification in rsa that
would
potentially be expanded but just so
people are aware
thank you representative woods and i
will note that representative
osborne is now with us
and we're we're about i suspect about to
take another roll call sir
representative osborne you may want to
unmute i yourself recommend
representative robert that he um
provides his location and yes
representative osborne could you just
tell us where you are and
whether there is anybody there with you
uh i'm in my home uh in my study
uh in camden new hampshire and no one
else is here
thank you very much representative are
there other
comments that people want to make
representative woods
point of order uh not trying to be picky
but
since uh representative osborne just
joined uh
is it still a cricket for him to vote
and not having been present for the
discussion a member may always
vote if they were present when the
question is put
and i have not yet put the question so
uh representative osborne not only may
vote
must vote because he is present
is there any other discussion
on the motion of not recommended for
further action on house bill 1265
being none when she is ready madame
clark you may call the roll
thank you madam chair champion yes
snow yes freitas
yes tysarst yes canarp
yes salloway yes
cannon yes nutter up him yes
osborne yes shapiro
yes woods yes
mcmahon yes nelson
yes dusry yes
marsh yes pearson
yes stapleton
yes and weber
yes i believe that would be 18 to zero
thank you very much madam clerk and
thank you i will close the executive
session on house bill 1265.
i will open up the work session on house
bill
1538 creating a commission to develop
and implement
environmental education outreach and
training programs and initiatives
for qualified health care professionals
relative to environmental
toxins and health
is there discussion
is the floor open for a motion to
approve
uh the floor is open and if you would
care to make that motion you may
may do so i'd like to move approval
okay so recommended for further action
yes and would you is there a second
um representative salloway would you
care to speak to your
um motion uh it's a logical continuation
of the work that we've been doing on
environmental risk
and chronic disease and now it's
imperative that we begin to get
information
out to our healthcare practitioners
to make them aware that the patients
that they're seeing
are not merely diagnosable but need to
be assessed
for the environmental risks that have
brought them in the first place
okay other comments
represent the woods uh
yes now being a co-sponsor i uh
basically in favor of the particular
action
however given the environment of uh
i don't mean no pun intended but with
the covid and all of our restrictions
and also the overlap with
[Music]
a currently functioning commission on on
chronic diseases i'm wondering if this
is something that we should perhaps
consider
doing for the time being um
i certainly uh it's aimed in the right
direction
and i'm fully in favor of that but
wanted to
re at least raise the question
i'm sorry representative woods i was
having a little bit of a difficulty
hearing you so are you recommending
uh going ahead with the recommendation
or not going ahead with the
recommendation and if you unmute
yourself again please that would be
helpful
yeah yeah i i will vote for it
but i just wanted to raise the issue as
we go
forward and further discussion uh in uh
comes comes forward that we at least
consider the context in which we're
asking this to be done thank you very
much thank you
uh yes can i raise a question uh i'm
going to take representative snow and
then i'm going to take representative
salloway and then i'm going to
look again so representative snow if you
wish to speak you may
yes i just had a question it was a
lengthy amendment
uh it was uh
1013h and that replaced the entire bill
and i'm assuming that that's what we're
voting on not the original bill as it
was presented
what we're voting on basically is the
entire
concept and so
we're simply recommending
that the whole concept be
resubmitted next time or not and of
course as you know
we have no control over the members of
the next
legislature it will be up to them
to determine whether this is resubmitted
and in what form
so if you would care to
you know say that you prefer the
um uh amended version we can certainly
we can certainly talk about that but the
ultimate recommendation is simply
whether
uh whether further action is needed or
further action is not needed
recommended rather i would just ask
representative salloway if
i think it was him that introduced this
amendment i
just know what his opinion was of that i
have no
quarrel with either one i guess it's up
to the representative that resubmits
to no but i just wondered what exactly
his opinion was
and representative salloway you're next
on my list so you may respond to that
i believe that representatives snow and
woods uh
bring their uh customary wisdom to this
committee
um and wonder if we might be able to
remand this
to the commission on environmental risk
and chronic disease
as an extension of their mandate and if
so how would we do that
okay first of all we have only two
options available to us
we write a report recommending further
action or we write a report
not recommending further action
if and that's further legislative action
i would suggest and i certainly
am subject to correction by anybody on
the committee
that if what is wanted is to refer
this matter to an existing commission
that we write a report that we
withdraw the recommendation for further
action
and write a report recommending no
further legislative action but include
in the language of the report
a suggestion that that particular
commission is the right place to discuss
it i mean that would be my suggestion as
to how to proceed but
members may have um a different thought
on that and i'll let representative
salloway respond first and then i'll
take representative woods
that would call for a vote of itl
and then a report to remand it to
another commission we don't take a vote
of itl
we have only the option of recommending
for further action
or not recommending for further action
thank you
so um we don't have to do an itl vote
because that's not something that's
available to us today as a
as a way to proceed um representative
woods you wanted to comment
uh yes thank you madam chair um that was
i didn't state it very well but
that's exactly what i would like to see
occur and i would refer to
uh because uh both uh representative
salloway and myself
are on that chronic disease commission
and i would just read that
articles 13 and 14 specifically state
that protocols be developed for
physician education
and guidelines for practice
so it specifically it includes
a to a significant degree overlap with
exactly what
uh 1538 wishes to accomplish
and so i would uh you said it much
better than i and that's what i would
like to see accomplish
okay i see representative campion but
before she speaks i'm going to ask
representative salloway if
he would consider if it feels
appropriate to him withdrawing the
recommended for further legislative
action
motion and if your second
also approves that perhaps we could have
the opposite motion
and consider accompanying it with a
report
that says that the legislature
believes or the committee believes if
the committee votes this way
that the further action that should be
taken should be taken
by the commission that's an excellent
suggestion madam chairman
thank you and i support that entirely
okay let me
take representative campion's comment
and then we'll work on that
thank you madam chair and it's really
just a procedural
comment i see that sai sharala's hand is
raised
as an attendee from the department and
she may
have information that would help guide
the committee's
vote okay um
if it's possible to get her in
okay uh if the committee wishes to hear
from her i'm going to ask ms dyer if
that is possible
absolutely if you if you if you'd like i
can allow her to talk
okay and before you do that i see the
clerk's hand raised and i'm going to
recognize
her thank you madam chair i will just
need help on the spelling correct
spelling of the name
okay we'll do that once we get her
admitted okay
okay uh she has been admitted and able
is able to speak now
and will you please ma'am state your
name
very clearly for the record and spell it
for the clerk
thank you so much for the committee for
allowing you to talk this is dr
sai chirala s a i sai
chirala c h e r
a l and welcome dr tirella
and you wish to say something yes um i'm
the bureau chief for the population
health and community services
i just want to thank representative
murphy and representative
woods for this legislation and uh
as we mentioned in our previous uh uh
process we did say that this would be
really suitable to sit under
the sb 85 the environmentally triggered
chronic illness
committee because in many ways it aligns
with their uh
prefer process and it provides that
and one thing we do want to also support
is new hampshire medical society is also
interested in providing this education
and um can support that and
uh the last thing that i do want to add
is senator shaheen has been
has proposed a specific legislation
that's focused on physician education
around pfas impacts
and that is uh some of that information
is being in the process and
is being legislated and that is also
similarly aligned with the same kind of
understanding that
uh increased er physician education
around pfas impacts and other issues
and we want to thank the representatives
for your support on how to align those
committees together
thank you so much dr tyrella and so you
would be comfortable with
um a report not recommending for further
legislative
action but for referral to the committee
yes we would be that that that company
is specifically focused on the
environmentally environmentally
triggered chronic illnesses
and their uh their mandate is also a
look at
understanding and providing further
education
both for the medical providers as well
as for the other providers so
this would be kind of this this work
would be
clearly supported in that work in that
commission
okay thank you very much for your
comments we appreciate them
um are there other comments at this
time i have a come on i've got
i put up my hand to raise it i'm not
sure you can hear me
right ahead representative guthrie we
hear you thank you thank you
just a matter of form who are we
recommending this
too what body takes this uh
recommendation and what sort of we do
have the flexibility of doing what has
been suggested here
uh representative woods would you state
again the name of the
body to which we are referring this no
i'm sorry madam chair i meant what
when we on any of these bills yeah
action further action how do we who do
we refer that
to we are just stating
our opinion we're not actually saying it
to anybody we are stating our opinion as
a committee
that something ought to happen or ought
not to happen
but because we cannot as a committee
bind any member of the next legislature
to do
anything we cannot tell anybody else
what to do
even if some of them are members
returning members who are
on this particular call so it
will be up to the next legislature to
either
introduce further legislation or not
introduce further legislation
and they can do that no matter what our
recommendation
is i understand that but what body
is this recommendation being made to
this specific
recommendation is being
made to the committee the name of which
representative woods is going to tell us
once more
well i misunderstood i think my question
is not specific and i think we're going
in the
right direction i'm just saying on any
of these bills
when we refer for further action
who are we referring that further action
too and who takes the action
we can we can only suggest
yeah we can't mandate that anybody
at all do any other thing in
this particular case we are going to
suggest
to this commission that they take
further action on this
issue when we get to the next
bill we will find out with the next bill
to whom people want to refer action
and we'll discuss that action and to
whom we refer it then
but this bill i'm going to
do it one more time because i actually
want to write down the name
representative woods
would you tell us the name of the
committee
it's the commission this is it this is
the commission
to study environmentally triggered
chronic
illness okay that's uh from
it's called senate bill 85
okay thank you very much that's helpful
for the specifics
um representative campion you had your
hand up thank you madam chair i mean
just responding to representative
guthrie's question
and is it not true that the in general
globally the recommendations
are being made to the next legislature
globally the recommendations are being
made to the next legislature that is
that is true so seeing no more hands up
i'm going to go back to representative
salloway
and ask him if he is willing to withdraw
the motion of recommended for further
legislation
so that another motion might be made
withdrawn
and representative nuterapam would you
withdraw your second
i do thank you very much representative
salloway do you wish to make a different
motion
uh i'd like to move that the matter
under consideration
uh be remanded to um
the recommended for further legislation
or not recommended for free it's
recommended for
further legislation i'm not it's
it's not recommended right
okay so the motion is not recommended
for further legislation
but with a note suggesting that this
issue be taken up by the sb 85
uh commission to study environmentally
triggered chronic illness which i have
now written down and committed to memory
uh is there a second to that motion
representative better open i see your
hand up so
we are going to second it take your
second on
that um is there further discussion
on the recommendation
none the recommendation to
the subcommittee is that
we not recommend for further legislation
but recommend
that this be taken up by the commission
to study environmentally triggered
chronic illness under sb 85
and when she is ready the clerk may call
the role
thank you madam chair and i just want to
clarify that i am
calling the role on the subcommittee
work session
correct okay very good champion
yes snow
representative snow you need to unmute
and vote
unmuted yes thank you all right
uh fridas yes tyshurst yes
canaric yes salloway
yes cannon yes
nutter up him yes osbourne
yes shapiro yes
woods yes mcmahon
yes nelson yes
guthrie yes marsh
yes pearson yes
act i'm sorry stapleton yes
and weber yes
that would be 18-2-0 okay
i am going to close the work session on
house bill 1538 and open the executive
session on house bill 1538.
and i am going to recognize the maker
of the motion in the work session
representative salloway
to make a motion to the executive
session uh i move inexpedient to
legislate
no you move either recommended for
further legislation
no further legislative action okay
um and do you wish to s
uh is there a second second
you face it yeah how do you get your
face uh i'm sorry who was it who
seconded
joe okay thank you representative
shapiro
um and representative salloway
do you wish to state what you might put
in a report
um it is the um
considered wisdom of the subcommittee
and the committee
that this matter uh be remanded to the
commission on environmental education
under sb 85
to implement as part of the mandate okay
thank you very much
is there further discussion
seeing none um
i'm going to ask the
clerk when she is ready to call the mo
the role on the motion of no further
legend the recommendation of no further
legislative action
on house bill 1538
thank you madam chair champion yes
snow yes freitas
yes twice first yes canark yes
salloway yes cannon yes
nadarapam yes osborne
yes shapiro yes
woods yes mcmahon
yes nelson yes
guthrie yes marsh
yes pearson yes
stapleton yes and weber
yes 18 to nothing
okay um i am now going to close the
executive session
on house bill 1538 and i'm going to open
the work
session on house bill 1610
fn establishing the manufacturer
pharmaceutical drug
take back program and open
the floor for discussion comment and
whatever anybody else wants to do with
it representative clerk i see your hand
yes i actually have a question a point
of information that i need to sort out
are we those of us who made the motion i
presume are responsible for a report
then and if so
how do you want us to submit them and by
what time
um i want you to submit a report
sometimes
say in the next 24 hours and i would
like you to email it to me
thank you and if there are
you know so we can work out um
whatever um my process will be to edit
it with you if
if i think there's any editing needed
and then i will forward it to ms dyer
for further
manipulation appropriate from the house
committee services as they normally do
and for inclusion in in a later calendar
so that's what will happen with that and
i thank you for the question
so that gets us back to the manufacturer
pharmaceutical drug
take back program questions comments
thoughts
representative shapiro i see your hand i
have a question
um not remembering the testimony
um on this bill i'm unclear if this is a
bill that mandates that manufacturers
will create a take back program or if
this is a bill that allows manufacturers
of these medications to create a take
back program
my recollection and i am again subject
to
uh correction by other members of the
committee
is this would mandate a take back
program but leave to the manufacturers
uh the a pro
the onus of proposing how they're going
to do it
they have every opportunity right now i
believe to take back and there are
voluntary take
back programs in that you know various
pharmacies and other places have drug
um or at least disposal programs
so i believe they could certainly do it
on their own they don't
need our permission but i think that the
intent
of the sponsor was to
ensure that it happened there are
mandatory programs in a few states and
i think that that was the the thought uh
representative osborne i see your hand i
think it's fairly clear
if you look at um
line 18 it says therefore the general
court hereby
establishes a uniform drug take back
program
operated and funded by drug
manufacturers
so it says we're going to do it that's
clear
thank you very much and thank you for
finding that uh representative woods
uh thank you madam chair um one of the
issues that came up uh in hearings and i
think if i
remember correctly since this would have
to be
not the oversight would be through hhs
and this would require three additional
people from what i understand
currently there's a hiring freeze
so there may be a difficulty and even if
we
voted to go forward for it to to fail
therefore at the moment i would say
no further legislation okay
representative marsh you had
i thought thank you madam chairman i i
wanted to point out that when we heard
the testimony
about this bill when the state was in
considerably better financial shape than
it is at this point in time
uh we were told that we have an existing
drug take back program that it's working
very well
and that this new program would cost
considerably more than the existing
program to implement
and therefore i'm of the opinion that
this program is not something that we
should go forward with
and if it's appropriate i would make a
motion that no further legislation is
called forward this time
that that motion is certainly in order
representative marsh so
representative marsh has recommended no
further legislation
um and i heard a second i thought
from representative woods
okay um
is there further discussion or
representative marsh did you want to
speak further on the issue i'm satisfied
um representative shapiro
i have a question of clarification um
since the intent of this bill seems to
put the financial onus on the
manufacturers who are making the money
um puts the financial onus on them to
run the take back program
where is how is this a more expensive
program for the state and is that
specifically to hire people within hhs
to oversee it
uh representative either woods or marsh
do you wish to respond to that
that's my recollection as well and i'm
at the disadvantage that my notes are
sitting in the drawer in the legislative
office building where
i can't read them but that's my
recollection yes yeah i have some note
i have some notes and then followed by
representative knark yeah
thank you ma'am share my apologies for
bursting in
it's quite all right my my um
notes do in fact uh identify and i think
they're correct
uh three three additional ftes
um would be required
a yes and the fiscal note
uh produced by dhhs did point that out
and said that the cost was going to be
um 106 000 in the first year going up to
230 000
in fiscal year 2023 because they do have
responsibilities
to collect data from wholesalers retail
pharmacies and so on and so forth
and uh by annual surveys and a number of
other features that did require the
hiring of new personnel madam chairman
make a point of order please
yes uh can we please recognize that
representative acton is now present and
given the opportunity to
say where he is and whether or not he's
alone thank you very much representative
acton
we are seeing you sideways but we are
very glad that you were
with us and if you would unmute your
uh microphone there you go and if you
would unmute your microphone please
and just let us know um
where where you are and and um
that you are or not are not accompanied
by another person
there is no wrong answer there we just
need to
note it for the record
still can't hear you representative
acton
that's much better welcome uh okay
uh thank you and and nice to see you all
um i apologize for being late
um i am at my house alone and i am
logged in using my iphone right now on
zoom
and i'm late but i'm i'm ready to go
we're very glad to see you and thank you
representative marsh for bringing that
to my attention
i believe just for your reference
representative acton we're working on
house bill 1610
the manufacturer's drug take back
program
and i believe i saw representative
stapleton's hand
waving at some point so representative
stapleton if you'd care to comment go
right ahead
yes thank you madam chair in addition to
the three positions for
uh department of health and human
services there are survey costs biennial
surveys and these things can be
expensive they sound innocent enough but
uh what do you put into a survey twenty
five thousand thirty five
and i noticed the figures from um
the fiscal note that uh or someplace
else that
if you put out a survey for ten thousand
people you might get a thousand back or
is it seven thousand out to get
one thousand back this is a lot of work
and uh i think they're just too much uh
for the short time that
that we have so um i i believe this
needs to go not
recommended and go on to the next
legislature
for their consideration and uh
well they may consider it in either case
but the recommendation that this we
can't
take any further action in this
legislative
session representative weber that i
interject for just one moment um i'm
just looking if
folks have this up on page 11 line 36
the program funding is clearly there
i just wanted to point out that it may
be read differently
and might one of folks might want to
take a look at it it's at the bottom of
page 11.
i'm sorry would you read us that
language
yes of course a covered manufacturer or
group of covered manufacturers
shall pay all administrative and
operational costs of sued
associated with establishing and
implementing the drug take back program
which they participate
this can include and i'm paraphrasing
here collection
transportation supplies purchase of
secure collection
authorized collectors prepaid mailers
compensation
authorized collectors operations
cost of law enforcement staff time
transportation of collected covered
drugs to final disposal
environmentally sound disposal a program
operator
covered drugs and compliance with 318 f7
and program promotion and outreach
but it do you
read it as saying or not saying that
the department's supervisory costs would
be covered by the manufacturers
i think it depends on i don't think that
it's clear in the language
it does offer to pay for oversight of
the program
administration but that particular
detail doesn't seem to be
noted here and i just wanted to point
that out thank you very much i
appreciate
that uh are there other comments
representative stapleton go ahead
followed by representative osborne i
see that on page 14 at
um beginning at line
10 uh the department shall impose
any fees in excess of its actual
administration
and it goes on to say they shall not
exceed 10
of the program's annual expenditures
so there's no idea what fees
that we're looking at here it's turning
it over to hhs to
determine the fee schedule as uh as well
as
all of the other uh details and figures
and the cost and operation of this and i
think that's a little too open
um especially for uh the circumstances
we find ourselves in now with covid
and tight budget thank you very much
representative osborne
uh once again from the
document itself they do estimate
um how much those specialists those
three specialists will
cost and it ranges um
from do do do twenty three thousand
dollars
forty seven thousand dollars and forty
nine thousand dollars are the
the the basic salary and benefits are
fourteen thousand
twenty nine thousand and thirty one
thousand so
you're talking about several hundred
thousand there yep
thank you um any further questions
comments or thoughts otherwise i
uh the motion was not recommended for
further legislation
and um on house bill
1610 and when she is ready the clerk may
call the role
you madam chair and i'm just confirming
that i'm calling the rule on
hv 1610 for the
subcommittee work session that's correct
okay campion yes
snow yes fridas
yes tice hurst yes canark
yes salloway yes
cannon
representative cannon we need you to
unmute and vote
yes okay nutter up him
representative natarapam are you still
with us i am sorry
yes osborne yes
shapiro yes woods
yes mcmahon yes
nelson yes guthrie
yes marsh yes
pearson yes acton
yes stapleton
representative stapleton we need you to
unmute and vote
yes thank you and weber yes
so that is now 19 to zero
okay and representative marsh you will
be doing the
um report oh no wait a minute we have a
whole new procedure
um i am now going to close the work
session on house bill 1610 fn
i'm still getting ahead of myself some
things never change
and i am now going to open the executive
session on house bill 1610 fn
establishing the manufacture
pharmaceutical drug take back program
and um i would
recognize representative marsh for a
motion
thank you madam chairman i move that we
recommend no further action on this bill
okay is there a second a second
um i i guess i got representative
salloway on that so if that's okay
or i guess the representative woods you
did it earlier is that right
representative salloway um
okay it has been moved and seconded uh
is that
there are any further remarks
representative marsh that you wish
to make i think we've spoken that we've
beaten this one to death
okay are there any further remarks from
anybody else
seeing none when she is ready
the motion is a recommendation of no
further action on house bill 1610 fn
establishing the manufacturer
pharmaceutical drug take back program
and when she is ready the clerk may call
the roll
thank you madam chair i'm sorry
i i'm just about to sneeze i think i'm
recovered
champion yes
okay um mckay
no sorry no snow
yes fridas yes
tysor's yes canark yes
dalloway yes cannon yes
nutter out them yes osbourne
yes shapiro yes
woods yes mcmahon
yes nelson yes
guthrie yes marsh
yes pearson yes
acton yes declare
oh sorry stapleton yes yes
and weber yes that would be 19 to zero
okay i'm going to close the executive
session on house bill 1610 fn
i am going to say that if you thought i
had trouble dealing with control issues
when we all sat
in our same seats the idea that the
pictures
on my screen rearrange themselves
regularly and with no forewarning or
rationale that i can figure out it
drives me nuts but i will say that it's
very nice
to be able to just move a little cursor
and have the names appear
because that's very helpful to those of
us with aging minds so i'm going to open
the work session on house bill 1616 fn
relative to the age for minors visits to
mental health practitioners
representative shapiro yes
um i was originally opposed to this bill
but um
given the documents from the researcher
suggesting that there are bills with
lower ages of consent for mental health
treatment in a variety of states
a variety of ages and a variety of
conditions put on that treatment
i am now open to this bill um
given that i think there are tremendous
deficiencies in the bill
as it is um written
so i would like to move to recommend
further legislation given
that this bill comes back in a different
form and i'll suggest
some of the things that i think need to
be done
okay let me see if i have a second to
that motion first i'll second that
uh representative snow has seconded um
so representative shapiro please go
ahead and
and state your your thoughts on it
okay so first um while none of us
want to see someone who is in
significant distress not be able to
obtain help because their parent is
emotionally unavailable or doesn't have
money
or is abusive in some way while we
all would not like to see a young person
slip through the cracks in that way
i don't think the sponsors of this bill
initially
established the need for this kind of
this kind of change there are ways that
young people can
can access treatment through a school
counselor through dcyf
so i think a better job needs to be done
about establishing the need
i think also a better job needs to be
done to establish why
the age of 12 rather than 14 or 16.
also the bill does not refers to
temporary treatment but does nothing to
define
temporary treatment if you look in the
documents
from the researcher some of the other
states do define
temporary treatment in terms of a number
of sessions or a number of months
so i think that needs to be fixed the
question came up in our hearing about
payment
if the parent is not to know about this
treatment
which is a distinct possibility if a
young person can give consent on their
own
who will pay if the insurance is not
accessible
a better job would have to be done to
describe
the confidentiality of records since
generally speaking a parent or guardian
has access to a young person's records
it would also have to be defined whether
this um
this kind of treatment includes
prescription of psychotropic medications
by a medical doctor
as well as psychotherapy
and lastly on my list anyway
is that i think um the hospital
association or hospitals in general
would have to be brought into this
discussion
because um it's very dicey to have a 12
year old admitted to the hospital
without their parents
knowing that they're being admitted and
possibly where they are even so i think
um there would have to be discussions
with other stakeholders including
hospitals because hospitalization is
mentioned as part of mental health
treatment in this bill
okay so if i may summarize
what you are talking about
is that a further legislation
needs to have more considerations about
age the
scope of the treatment the duration of
the treatment
the conditions of the treatment as well
as issues of confidentiality
and i i'm thinking about the
hospitalization part as being
part of the scope and range of treatment
that
falls under the bill is that correct yes
okay thank you other thoughts uh
represent osborne followed by
representative woods followed by
representative snow
when i first read this i was um in favor
of it but
i've researched some about all the
different states that have
all different plans sometimes you can
tell a parent sometimes you can't
and they do talk about cost uh i think
this is simply
too simple what we have here i
i think uh i agree with uh
representative shapiro
that it it needs further study it's an
important
subject but it needs further study
okay thank you um representative woods
um i i can concur that this is an area
that this is a chance
to intervene at an age when we can
really make a difference
um and i think it it behooves us to
this carefully uh but not
step into a wormhole someplace
the other question um is the difficulty
of
of and wasn't answered sufficiently
at least in my notes uh the issue of the
federal um statutes uh and significant
note was made that
conceivably violates federal law and
might
endanger some of the funds that are
currently in place
if it were to go through under its the
current guys
representatives snow you had a comment
yes i have i agree completely with
everything that everyone has said
i was contacted i think we all remember
some of the testimony we heard in
committee especially
from a young woman who was now at unh
who refused the ability to seek
treatment until she turned 18
was at the university and the remarkable
recovery she's made as a result of that
so there certainly is a reason why we
should proceed with this but this
bill needs a lot of work but one thing
the researchers said that the average
age for all the
states that have uh this kind of
legislation is 15.
so there's only two that i could see
that had 12 is an eight
and that seems very young that's seventh
grade that
you know there is a little bit of a
problem in terms of how early you
intervene in a family's
situation they do have dcyf for some
other problems but they don't
another is that whole issue of temporary
and that's defined all over the place
uh but we need to have a very definite
definition about what temporary means
uh confidentiality is a big problem
eobs will have to go out two parents
most of these children if they aren't on
medicaid
will have a be covered under their
parents insurance whatever that is
how the accountable care act or just
private insurance
and the eob goes to the parents so
they're going to know right away that
they do
certain information and at this point
i've heard of
practitioners where they've been
threatened to be sued
if they didn't also send their notes so
i think we need to make very
sure that the protection of the exact
records is protected and this bill
didn't seem to
uh to really cover that and i read the
medicaid
rules about this and it's very unclear
about exactly what's coming
the issue of medication this bill says
everything is covered but it doesn't
include
the inclusion of medication by a medical
doctor
right and i'm going to remind people
that we're not
writing the future legislation we're
just deciding whether
or not or shouldn't have future
legislation i was contacted by
uh the young woman who who uh submitted
this bill
uh her name is i think it's nicole
representative wine night yeah by night
yes
and she's the first thing she's very
very she's definitely going to resubmit
this bill no matter what we do but i did
urge her to
take a little time to work on it a
little bit i brought she asked me to
help her design it and i
did not accept that i said i thought she
had to go to legislative services
that they would be very helpful to her
but i did mention the issue of age and
confidentiality
but another thing that i think is not
included in this bill is some provider
protection there's going to be lawsuits
by parents if they start seeing somebody
and i don't think a lot of the
practitioners or agencies are going to
want to be bothered
with a legal expense even though they're
on firm ground
of having parents suing in order to get
clinical notes
uh seeing as the law is pretty clear
that they have a right to medical
information
under children and i guess the final
thing is that um
well i get i think that's enough but i
completely agree with what everybody
said
but i do think i would hope that somehow
we looked at a way
of in a meaningful way put a piece of
legislation in place
because suicide rates are going high the
kids are in
recognition of it and many times it's
not because of abusive or drug abusing
parents
this particular girl it's because a lot
of people who are socially prominent
or whatever it is don't want their kids
to go into treatment
because of the possibility they'll
reflect badly in their family
and we need to avoid those barriers to
treatment for kids so
i'll shut up at this point but i do okay
representatives know you had something
else to say no i think
representative shapiro already made a
motion i don't want to repeat it so
okay the motion has been made the motion
is recommended for further action
representative marsh
thank you madam chairman uh i'm afraid
that i
i will not be able to vote in favor of
this motion i think
that it is intimately
related to the informed consent laws in
the state of new hampshire and as we
know minors are not
legally able to give informed consent
unless they've been emancipated or dcyf
gets involved or
other legal matters happen which there
are mechanisms for those things to
happen
without informed consent uh
practitioners
uh even if we allow them to do treatment
their insurers
their malpractice insurers are not going
to permit them to do so or it would
become
exorbitantly expensive for them to do so
even if we have a mechanism to pay for
it i think these are
are really huge complications with this
concept at this point in time
um i i don't see a way of fixing them so
i'm going to vote against further action
thank you very much representative marsh
uh representative shapiro yes
i would just remind the committee that
um according to federal law
um people as young i think as 14
can already access family planning
and substance use disorder treatment
so um this would not be completely new
thank you very much are there any
further comments representative
stapleton
yes madam chair i uh am opposed to the
motion
and i'm troubled with uh lack of uh
for the exclusion of certain parent uh
parental uh consent and involvement
i think that's a dangerous protocol
there may be well there is
time and need for a special exception
i don't think the bill reflects the
precision necessary
to handle those things and instead it
broad brushes
and impugns the parental
rights and prerogatives to be involved
and to
provide for payment and care and to be
part of the decision
so i'm going to oppose the motion thank
you very much
madam chair uh representative
um shapiro and then representative snow
i would just like to say that i share
representative stapleton's concern
being a family therapist for most of my
career i think that
most issues that young people face
are not going to be adequately addressed
without including their family
so i um also am concerned about
um excluding family excluding parents
um however i think there are some
situations
where the parents are unable to be
helpful
and i would hope that in a future bill
um there could be some way to discern
whether it's really necessary for a
young person to give consent
and exclude parents i think that's very
tricky to do
but that would be my hope because i do
think excluding parents is a concern
thank you for your comments
representative snow
yes i agree with what he said uh
representative shapiro said but
in some of the other states there's a
concept called mature
minor and they they somehow define that
and it puts the onus on the provider
that sees them
to determine that this seems to be a
reasonable and mature decision
being made by a minor and that the
therapist or the provider
document why they established that fact
and is determined to try
very hard to get the family involved
because many times with kids problems if
you don't include the family you're
not going to really get anywhere anyway
but
and they if they do make the
determination that the family should not
be involved
that they have very clear documentation
about why they made that decision
but that should be included in the law
thank you very much for your comments
uh seeing no further representative
woods yes
uh thank you manager um uh just a
slightly different perspective i realize
and i i
put forth my own concerns about the
federal issue
um but overall my
guiding principle is this is an age
group
where we can really make a difference
and we have to look at it
um there are a lot of deficiencies but
oftentimes at least in my perspective
when i talk to my constituents
sometimes we bring forward legislation
so that we can develop a social dialogue
and gain critique but without that
public discussion and the awareness on
the public
and the awareness for from legislators
on a continued basis we'll never have
discussion
so i think given the age group that is
extremely vulnerable and has impact
in a multitude of dimensions farther in
life
i think it's worthy of going forward if
nothing more than to keep the
the conversation going and raise all of
the issues
and even if we're not in the legislature
next time
those in the legislature will look at
the issue afresh
and probably raise exactly the same
questions and maybe have
better solutions thank you
representative woods
the motion is recommended for further
legislation on house bill 1616 is there
any
further discussion seeing none
when she is ready the clerk may call the
role and this is the roll call
for the work session only so
when you're ready madame clerk perfect
thank you madam chair
champion yes snow
yes greatest yes
tysar's yes canard
yes yes salloway no
cannon yes nutter up him yes
osbourne yes
i'm sorry that was not clear to me would
you repeat it yes
shapiro yes woods
yes nelson
no oh wait a minute i skipped over
mcmahon i'm sorry so
mcmahon no and now nelson
no guthrie
representative guthrie you need to
unmute
unmute your microphone
yeah that's why i had a question because
i'm having trouble
can you hear me now yes we can hear you
now yes
and nobody sees my hand but my vote is
no
okay no representative guthrie marsh
oh pierson
representative pearson do you care to
vote
could you unmute yourself and vote
orally please
oh thank you did i hear no
representative pearson others need to be
able to hear your reply
they can't i'm unmuted and i'm saying no
thank you thank you
we didn't hear that thank you okay acton
no stapleton
no and weber
yes
i have 11 in 11 yays and
eight nays okay um
with that i will close the work session
on house bill 16
16 the eighth for minors visits
to mental health practitioners and i
will open up the executive session
on the same bill and i will represe
recognize representative shapiro for a
motion
i move to recommend hb
1616 for further legislation
thank you is there a second yes
representative snow has seconded is
there further discussion
seeing no further discussion uh
when she is ready the clerk may call the
role
thank you madam chair campion
yes snow yes
prietas yes tice first yes
canark yes falloway
uh representative salloway are you still
with us i know representative salloway
said he needed to leave at 3
30. so representative salloway are you
still with us
okay um so if you will mark him as
absent
okay and canon
yes not a wrap him
yes osborne
yes shapiro yes
woods yes mcmahon
no nelson no
guthrie no marsh
no pearson
acton no stapleton
no and weber
yes
this time i have 11 to 7. that would be
correct
because representative salloway has left
us
okay i am closing the executive session
on house bill 1616
fn and i am uh opening the
work session on house bill 1665
fn relative to investigations of sudden
undetermined infant deaths parenthesis
suid by the office of the chief medical
examiner
and so are there comments thoughts
adam cheer uh
representative guthrie i'm just going to
recognize miss dyer first but i
i saw you sorry
weber i wanted to let you know that we
received information that
um representative camarota is in the
attendees and she wished
to speak on the bill as the sponsor i
just wanted to let you know that her
hand is raised
okay i'm going to have the committee
speak
first and then we will get to that uh
representative guthrie you had a yes
madam chair
if my memory served me right by looking
at my notes
that there was a real problem getting uh
in the state and that in fact that they
are overburdened
presently in the job they're trying to
do now i thought that we heard testimony
for that fact and on that basis to give
them another
job if you will i think is not
wise legislature
okay other comments from the committee
yes right representative snow go ahead
according to my notes
we heard from the medical examiner's
office and others
that although we understand people
concerned about making sure everything
is done
to track down the reasons why an infant
dies
suddenly the medical examiner said they
do
all the tests that are presently
available and there's nothing else they
can do
under these circumstances and she said
she felt the bill was not necessary
to do a thorough job in examining why
children die
suddenly and unexpectedly
thank you representative snow
representative woods
um yes indeed and i'm just looking back
at her letter
uh that she provided in testimony uh
that
some of the the tests are are all the
tests that can be done are being done
and some of the
requests that were made are just not
feasible
okay um are there other questions or
comments from the committee
uh i will then take yes representative
camarado may comment
hello this is rep camarada
welcome representative camerota and
you're recognized to speak to the
committee
thank you so much and let me just before
you start
remind you that this is not the time for
new testimony
this is just the time to argue whether
this should be recommended for further
legislation or not recommended for
further legislation
i understand thank you um
i was hoping that the
amendment 2020 0
656 was discussed
at the committee level i'm not sure if
that was the case
that amendment basically just
asks that the office of medical examiner
followed the federal law with regard to
reporting to bears
can anybody um
answer the question as to whether
the amendment was discussed i have a cop
i have a copy
of that let me just answer that on
behalf of the committee
we certainly had the submission and the
committee
and the committee members are aware of
that submission
and we'll take it into
account in in making our recommendation
thank you um and in respect
to that amendment i would like the
committee
to consider the importance of collecting
raw data so that we don't miss something
we don't yet understand
we do have an increase in sued cases so
with cases both nationally and new
hampshire that's not debatable
and if we collect data
we may see trends
and when you see trends then you
research further and that would be put
on theirs at a federal level
versus the new hampshire level but we
have to report it
for these reasons i asked the community
to vote in favor of
recommending further legislation because
it has merit
in order to bring new hampshire into
compliance with federal law
thank you thank you very much for your
comments and your attendance today
thank you representative marsh
uh thank you madam chairman i would like
to say that i agree with representative
camarada
uh i think that the minority amendment
which would simply require
that the reporting to the veer system be
done
is appropriate and it's probably even
more appropriate now
when we are considering fast tracking uh
certain vaccinations which may be
enrolled to the public
with perhaps less than adequate testing
uh
i think that that to compromise the
vaccine monitoring system
uh when children could conceivably die
from side effects would not be wise
and and therefore i agree that further
legislation
not to the extent of the original bill
but to the extent of the minority
amendment
uh would be appropriate thank you very
much i'm just going to state
my own personal deeply held conviction
on this bill that i think that
based on what we have heard
that the medical examiner is
doing what uh is required to be done
and really is following
is is doing everything that
can be done both to bring a resolution
to a parent who is grieving the loss of
a child
which is a terrible thing and also
to increase the availability of
scientific
knowledge so my own
feeling on the matter is that it should
not be recommended for further
legislation
uh but that's just um i'm speaking from
a personal level there
rather than anything else uh i see
representative knurk has his hand up
thank you very much madam chair uh one
of the points made by the chief medical
examiner in her
uh testimony both oral and written is
that
new hampshire is one of 22 states that
participate in the suid
and the sdy which is sudden death and
the young
uh case registry and the advantage of
that is
that you're not just getting the
inference you're getting infants and
young
and the idea in this is you're taking a
problem
death you're then going to look at all
the factors that may be involved the
various bias is it because it says
you had a vaccine and there was a
concern so you're already
kind of coloring the data by bringing it
in
for a and for an intervention that was
done
and gathering data on that rather than
looking at an outcome which is
death and looking at potentially all the
causes that may be there
and including a broader age group that
covers the age of vaccination
beyond just infants so that is a program
which is already
if you see a trend that um you know
we have a number of kids who are dying
and we find out that there is a common
factor of vaccines in excess
of other factors that would then open up
a door
for further investigation and i think is
a parallel process to bears but a
cleaner way to gather up the scientific
data
thank you representative knark uh do we
have a motion at this point
oh i raised my hand oh i'm sorry
representative frieda
i beg your pardon go ahead and go ahead
thank you so much i just have had a lot
of communication with people
about this bill and much of it has to do
with the connection
to vaccines and what they're asking
is is that documented in any way that
the
death of the child the child had been
vaccinated
in the recent past and so i don't know
whether that is out of what the
medical examiner has in his report now
or is this going to be something that
this group is asking to have
added to my understanding
is that the uh scheduled of vaccines
that a child
who has this form of death
the schedule of vaccines is part of a
child's medical records
that the medical examiner will look on
look
at in any case of child death so
that is definitely part of what they are
looking at
no in any case
i believe that that was what the the
medical examiner testified to
thank you very much it would be part of
the examination
uh under any circumstances and it would
be part of the record
uh as to what vaccines the child had
received and when
representative snow has his hand up as
well uh
i'm going to have representative snow
and then i believe representative nelson
also wishes to speak
representatives now yes i i do have a
note here on
on that i wrote down on the amendment
when it was passed out to us
and the medical aim that did say that in
all cases of a
sudden infant death syndrome if they've
had vaccinations that the
the test is done and the report is made
to the ba
uh what is it uh vex uh
vaccine address events reporting system
so she's already doing that
so i don't think we would need this in
order to compel her to do it
they're doing it as an automatic product
when they do that exam
thank you representative snow and
representative nelson you wanted to
comment
yes matter chairman i more have a
question i'm
wondering if anybody counts a child
pre-born child that
may be aborted or uh
die before their births anybody count
that as to possibly
uh does that fit in counting the number
of people that might have a
uh problem with a vaccine or something
do they include kids
pre-born they wouldn't have had a
vaccine yet
we it's not the only person who might
have had a vaccine in that case would
have been the
mother rather than the fetus um
but this bill does not deal with that so
i think that that's another issue
representative nelson you wanted to
comment further yeah we're so interested
in getting this information which i do
think we should
it should be i would think you would
somehow
uh pre-born child and fetus that you
would want to know if the mother had a
uh some kind of shot a couple weeks
before and all of a sudden leave the
baby
still born thank you representative
um ms dyer were you trying that's my
apologies you have several attendees
that um
have their hands up i'm not sure if you
want to entertain them but um
you have representative judy aaron
sideshirala
and jenny duvall with their hands up as
a team this is not a further public
hearing so i accorded one representative
the courtesy of speaking
but this is actually the time i will say
to all of them
that this is the time for the um
committee to be making their discussions
and um it's not the time for further
testimony so
uh i'm going to recognize representative
campion and then representative tyshurst
and then representative knerk and then i
will inquire
further uh representative
champion thank you madam chair i would
just like
to reinforce representative connerk's
comment
about the order in which one might ask
the question about the effect of a virus
or i'm sorry a vaccine
on death not the virus
got it on the brain right now and that
is that if we go
looking for a particular cause and
collect data about the cause
before we understand the outcome that
the answer will be
what we're looking for we will def we
will find
a connection between vaccines and sudden
unexpected infant death if we start
as representative kenork suggested with
a child has died which is a tragic
circumstance
and then seek to understand whether
there is anything that has
occurred either in the immediate
past or over some time to affect that
child's health
and survivability we'll have a better
understanding
from a scientific perspective about
whether or not there exists a
relationship between vaccines and or
any other either environmental or
other cause so i will i will vote
not to recommend i would vote against
recommending further legislation thank
you
you recommend representative campion
representative tycerst you were next
thank you madam chair um i guess for me
um this is a a terribly difficult
subject but i feel that
um whether we vote to recommend or don't
vote to recommend is kind of neither
here nor there because
legislation is likely to come up i'm
probably going to vote against
further legislation just because i think
we need to
um start fresh i think this bill had
some problems and may have been overly
complicated
thank you thank you representative um
representative knurk yes i
i agree with you that we should not be
hearing uh testimony again but if
doctor sai sharala is in the audience
and asking to comment
i think we should hear from her as the
director of the public health
uh was i'm sorry was dr cycerella
one of the people who wished to comment
yes she was
i'm sorry i misunderstood that and
misheard that
uh so yes if you would uh admit dr
sharella okay here we go
and dr sharala you're able to speak
welcome back dr shirella thank you so
much for the committee for
taking uh taking my uh comments uh
thank you so much for all the all the
information that everyone is talking
about this
uh actually just to point out uh dr
duval jenny dual who is our
office of chief medical examiner she is
also on
call she also raised her hand so if
there are any follow-up questions she
can also answer some of the co
make some comments on that but has i
wanted to talk to
wanted to point out what uh
representative
conduct has pointed out uh new hampshire
is one of the uh 22 states that has the
suit
the sudden unexplained infant death
registry
so we actually follow every suit that in
our state
and we have a suite committee that
actually looks at
all of these cases they review
and try to understand what are the con
what's what is happening
for this child to have that kind of
situation so they look at the medical
history
they understand the physical uh any kind
of issues that under
whether it is the sleep environment are
there some other factors that are
involved
so they do a very in-depth kind of
review
of the case so they try to understand
what it is
and then they that they use that
information to point out
what a public health campaigns or more
medical provider education
or even kind of provide more services to
the families who might need them
including like home visiting uh parent
education or unsafe sleeps
a safe sleep kind of those kind of
things
those are some of the things that are
done and has a part of review they also
ask questions that on vaccine history
whether what kind of vaccination that
the child had or the infant had before
uh before that event so those are some
of the things that are taken uh
taken into account and actually part of
that also
is they do follow um the families
basically for a great
grievance grief process and provide
resources to the families about what
kind of things that they can do
and they are the resources that they can
access to
so if there are any other follow-up
questions i would be ha
i would um i can answer any of those
questions but i also
have dr jenny duval from office of chief
medical examiner is also on the call
okay
again we're trying very hard not to take
new testimony
does the committee want to hear for dr
dewall as well
and if does doctor i'm here seeing uh
okay so if you could admit dr dewall
pardon me madam chair but could i also
have the spelling of her name
uh dr paul are you with us i think so
can you hear me we can hear you and if
you would state your name and spell your
name for the benefit of the clerk
yes uh jenny j e n n i e
duval d u v a l okay
thank you very much welcome and um
your uh clarifications
um i i was just making myself available
to answer any
questions um i think that uh
what dr representative kenner and
representative campion said is
is very true if we're talking about this
amendment
which i haven't seen the text of but it
sounds like
an amendment that would require us to
report
all suid deaths to the vaccine adverse
event reporting system
and as as has already been mentioned i
think that would
um muddy the data if if every
medical examiner office did that then
all sewage would be
would be you vaccine and i think that
would be a disservice
and um it would not help us in the least
trying to find an explanation for these
deaths
thank you very much dr duvall um
representative woods uh just to expand
on that a moment oh i think what she's
referring to
and i uh wish our other representative
who's an epidemiologist that left us but
that's by the the structure of that data
collection is by definition
conformational what's called
conformational bias
uh and as a consequence uh the data is
not just muddied but in essence is valid
thank you doc representative woods
um any further questions for dr duval
doctor mike excuse me go ahead
representative snow
my understanding was during the
testimony in the amendment
that you already did report it to the
vaccine thing
if there was any reason to believe that
this sudden infant death
was a result of a back seat not
reporting every single
uh sudden infant death thing but if
if it is evident that it is from some
procedure that you're doing you already
report that is that not correct uh
representative snow i think there's a
confusion here about the different
bodies to which things may be reported
and if dr duvall
could clarify for us
what to whom she reports and under which
circumstances
that would be helpful i yes so
we would certainly report to theirs
the va ers any death that we suspected
was caused by a vaccine
but as i understand it this amendment
is requiring us to report
any death temporally associated with
vaccine administration
and and that would i don't think would
be appropriate
um because the data is becomes
meaningless
you know temporal relationship is does
not mean cause
thank you very much dr devel um
are there any further questions for dr
duvall
seeing none uh i
would entertain perhaps emotional at
this point
i'm not making an emotion
i can't someone make a motion
who's speaking please representative
snow
representative snow go ahead i make a
motion that
uh no further action be taken on this
bill
on this bill 16 16
representative snow has moved no further
action than who was the second
representative woods um
is there further comments we have
certainly heard a great deal of comment
from people both for and against
that particular emotion
is there further discussion
i don't see any further discussion
so the motion is a recommendation of no
further action
uh no further legislation uh
and when she is ready on house bill 1666
and when she's ready the clerk may call
the roll
thank you madam chair and i'm just
confirming that this is the work session
vote
okay champion yes
no yes friedas
yes ty's hurst yes canark
yes dallas oh sorry cannon
yes great nutter up him
yes yes
shapiro yes woods
yes mcmahon yes
nelson yes guthrie
yes marsh no
pearson yes
acton no
stapleton no weber
yes
i have 15 in yes and three no
okay that i will close the
work session on house bill 1666
fn and i will open the
executive session with respect to
astonishingly enough house bill 1666
fn relative to investigations of sudden
undetermined
infant deaths suid by the office of the
chief medical examiner
and i will recognize representative snow
for a motion
i move that no further action be taken
on
legislative action be taken on house
spill 1666.
thank you representative snow is there a
second
yes uh representative woods has again
seconded is there any further discussion
on 1666
uh seeing none uh when she is ready
the clerk may take the
uh roll call on the executive session
vote on house bill 766.
thank you madam chair champion
yes snow
representative snow how do you vote
shall i come back to representative snow
uh why don't we pass over represent
snow could you just give us a yes or no
he's on the phone i i understand that
representative snow can i just have a
yes or a no from you please
you are muted
i'm now unmuted yes you are
what am i answering yes or no to the
roll call vote on house bill 1666 on
your motion
yes uh yes yes thank you okay
priedus yes tyshurst yes connor
[Music]
yes shapiro yes
woods yes mcmahon
representative mcmahon can you unmute
yourself
apologize for that i thought i did that
uh yes okay
nelson yes guthrie
yes marsh no
pearson yes
acton no
stapleton no
weber yes i believe that would also be
15 to 3.
okay and with that i am going to close
the executive session on house bill 1666
fn
and that uh brings us to the end of our
work for this term
and i just want to thank every one of
you from the very bottom of my heart
for the amount of work and effort
that you have put in on behalf of
the citizens of new hampshire this
session
nobody could have possibly had
a more uh dedicated
committee to work with and it's it's
been a real honor and a real pleasure
for me
so i just wanted to thank you all very
very much good job madam chair
yes thank you madam chief thank you
everyone i'll miss you all
it's been a pleasure and it's nice to
see her does that mean you're not coming
back
that means she's not coming back it does
not fight yeah not running and i'm going
am i going to do what i'm going
to smile in face mary you'll have to
pick up the slack
is there anybody else who is on the call
who is not running again
oh joy nice i'm glad you're all running
i'm very very pleased that those of you
who are running i'm very sad that
representative campion is not but i
uh know that she has other things that
she has
on her agenda so we we all wish her
very very well with that and thank you
so much for all of your work
um this term thank you
this is this committee has been the
highlight of my legislative
activities and i will miss you all i'll
come visit and sit in the gallery
we will be very glad of that we hope
that there will be
a gallery to sit in
and i just perhaps the virtual gallery
from
the bottom of my heart about the efforts
that you've put in to deal with really
terribly difficult situations and
um if if we can figure out a way of
nailing down the pictures on the zoom so
they don't
move around that fabulous but uh
thank you to ms dyer for and and to the
other staff members who are helping us
out because
uh they have really made this possible
and i
and we appreciate the enormous work that
you put in behind the scenes
to make all of us look uh relatively
good
so thank you and uh unless
anybody else has anything for the good
of the organization with that i am going
to
one question i know we have to do a
report on the one
on on the one bill where there was an
additional recommendation but the other
sponsors do not have to write a note
everybody has to write a brief report
and if you have questions about how that
report should go representative snow i
would i am available to everybody who
needs to write a report to help them
with that
okay so um
the person who made the motion is the
person who writes the report
and so i will be glad to help out with
that in any way i can
but we need to get them done relatively
quickly
so that representative dyer can go on to
her other committees that she has to
deal with
so thank you all very much and happy
weekend
well mary uh representative friedas has
a her hand up i'm sorry
go ahead sorry about that just to say
goodbye i guess
to wave it is the problem with
zooms that we just end and all vanish
and i really hate that as a way of
ending meetings there's no
farewell or real um
sitting around afterwards and chatting
but thank you all very much
and all good luck to all of you
bye-bye everybody bye all thank you
thank you all